I was in San Diego prior to going to
Tucson and uh San Diego at one point was
accounting for about 60 of all hard
narcotics meth Coke fentanyl oh wow San
Diego crazy a lot of it come through the
ports and then some of it coming between
the ports but in Arizona it started to
pick up and the difference in Arizona
was they were making these little blue
tablets fentanyl tablets which is much
easier to smuggle and transport than
than you know bricks of the stuff
so you would get and the way these guys
operate is it's just phenomenal
um so the scenario described right
here's the diversion I sent a group of
three guys three to five all of them
with the backpack all of them carry well
the way they would work it is the first
guy would have
20 30 pounds of marijuana right next guy
food and supplies the third guy would
have the Fentanyl and he would be
carrying
probably 10 to the most 20 pounds of
Fentanyl and then the other two guys
maybe math Coke something else and so
this group of five would come run across
the border we would hope that we would
pick them up you know if we're not what
we try to do is not get so distracted
that we've completely avoided everything
because again we had air assets
technology until you see this group and
then
the the the group had the Five Guys the
first guy his job was to get arrested
right so that yeah dealing with him and
the and the guy with the fentanyl his
job was to get away and the other four
guys would do everything in their power
to make sure that he got away dang it
was just it's like crazy Chiefs almost
kind of you know it's almost like
playing against Andy Reid in a way you
know what I'm saying like they're coming
with a plan oh yeah absolutely one of
the things that that also happens like
these five guys that are coming across
they're gonna hike for
30 to 80 miles through the desert
so these cartels have logistical
waypoints along there where they they
pay so many to haul in food and water
fresh batteries and so they're set up in
the desert and the mountains there so as
this group comes along they're watching
so they got two jobs one is to resupply
and then the second job is to watch us
and it is it's it's a bear to catch them
I mean in order to arrest these guys at
one point we did surveillance for
probably four to six months
identifying all the spots right and then
we brought in
um
we brought in a whole slew of air assets
um Blackhawks and everything else and we
brought in our Vortec which is like our
SWAT team yeah and a boar star which our
search and rescue team all these guys
are badass yeah and uh so we pinpointed
all these locations we coordinated with
the Mexicans and you know I mentioned
corruption so we had to coordinate with
Mexico City to bring out a vetted unit
that we could trust ah and so you know
they they did the blocking on on the
Mexican side so these guys couldn't run
south and get away and then we flew all
these teams in at each of these spots
and they'd repel down and they run in
the mountains and make these arrests but
you know the amount of money and effort
that goes into it tremendous but the
unfortunate part is you give it a week
maybe maybe a month
and then they're right back in business
and so then you have to replicate this
you have to start watching them and
tracking them and it's just crazy can
you tag them or something or shoot them
with like a dart so you know where they
are they don't allow that no no see
that's ridiculous to me a little bit
like it's almost like especially for the
guys who are doing the smuggling can you
uh because we'll tag a goose you know
what I'm saying to find out where he's
having an egg but you won't tag somebody
who's freaking just running you know
like anything across the border
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one